Good morning, hope you're having an amazing day. It's mark Wiens
The plan for today is
In about 15 minutes, we are driving back towards out of an inch, which is where we came from yesterday
And by the way, this is a two-part video series
So if you haven't seen the first part go back and watch the first part, but we're driving to Oedipa Minch
Which is a two-hour drive and from there
we're gonna explore the daughter xea tribe and we're gonna go to a village and that happens to be where deci from Goa desu is
From us so it's gonna be an honour to visit his village to learn about their culture
the tribe and the food
One of the things that they're known for is false banana, which we're both gonna learn about and explore
So right after we finish breakfast, we're heading out look at how yellow it is though. I
Think their onions in there
You can always count on the coffee to be great in Ethiopia. Ah, this is what they were blending back in the kitchen mango juice
Oh, yeah, that's just straight-up mango blended. Oh, it's thick and rich and delicious. That's really good
were Jumping out of the truck real fast because on the side of the road. We saw some of the unique gravestone
Markers, that is him. Who was the hero and then the one from the left left head?
The one from the wall, so this is like a whole family
We called Wacka Wacka
Wacka is the name of this statue
Yeah, we're just driving past this side of the road oh look at the look at the truck now
People saying hi to Micah now guys, huh
We drove all the way through the banana fields again and then threw out of a Minch
And now we're on the other side of the city and we're going up high into the mountains
We're really getting high here gaining elevation getting into the misty peaks of the mountains the pine trees
Oh man, the views. It's really wet too and starting to just miss
Both of you guys are from this area. Yeah. Okay. We have reached dough today
Wow, that is some cold fresh air. We picked up one of their friends
I
Think we're stopping here. Oh
This is this is beautiful. Well, that's an
amazing Hut
We're gonna step into the main hut and it's it's spectacular the construction. They're known to look like an elephant with the front section
like the giant nose and then there's eyes to look look like
Chimneys, I'm gonna step inside
Yeah, I think we need the light
Is there a lamb back there that's
Really big in here you can see that the ceiling at the top there the arched ceiling
But it's really nice and warm in here compared to outside
and then the seats if you can see if you can see are made from cowhide and
Eucalyptus. Yeah, cool. I'm gonna take a take a seat
Oh, oh, yeah, they kind of like revolve and kind of recline like like hammock cow skin
This is your home. Yeah, this is your yeah. I've been I was born and raised in a house like this
so you're on endorsing  which is the elevation of
2500 meters above sea level and there is a mainly known for weaving
Okay, they weave their closes their fences. If you saw the fence is found even the house is made by
Waving process and is it mostly bamboo everything out for them? hello
So there is a when the milky is boiling they would be putting the dabula which is the squeezed fermented kind of
banana false banana
Okay
So this is the false banana, yeah home false banana
We call it bula if they just brought in the plate of bula, which is the false banana
It has this sour aroma to it because it's been fermented
And then it's kind of powdery right now
Who is have a button taco much as in the olden days to go to Italy my token either those they are become you listen
He's just whisking that and she has this kind of fork made from bamboo
That she's stirring as she adds the false banana and then just whipping that up into
Into the porridge and you can hear that just start to bubble away and steam. Oh
Hi, Micah
Ok stepping out of the hut right now as she's making that but I wanted to see her pounding the coffee very fresh coffee less
Coffee leaves so they're making a coffee
Leaf drink a tea and it's very very cold for a good for cold Wow
And we think that's something I've never big
She place after she make the tea coffee leaves
And you can see the smoke coming from the top of the elephant hut there that's coming from the
The fire that we're cooking on. Ok, I'm going back into that hot to to keep cooking. Ok. This is butter. Ah
And bigger this is the garlic
Is it also called case
Vii of always immediately. Sometimes they put lemon wasn't Wow, listen up my school my dad necessary, but
She added in some powder fenugreek and then that's going in the burden she's still kind of whipping it up
What Mitchell made
Another dish that she's gonna make it is false banana also, but it's a stir-fried or fried version
So she had this she has this metal pan a rounded pan
she stuck over the fire and then she put the rest of that false banana and then she's just kind of
Mixing it on that hot plate
So she takes some of this but it's muttered also and garlic in London very spice one and then some bacon
She's now oh she's gonna make that that coffee
Leaf tea which is going on the fire right now
But I think we're gonna go get started eating and then she will put some garlic
Into the tea and the tea Wow garlic that is very spicy
well, oh, wow the cooking and the whole process in this Hut and the culture is just
fascinating you walk into the back of the hut here's the side of the
elephant hut these are the false banana trees and yeah bamboo as you can see is it's a
Lifeline I in the daughter set bamboo and false bananas are two of the most important
Substances materials both for construction for for livelihood and for food
Not to make it cold that is the poet that she was throwing this is the right the frame, okay
We are sitting down to eat. This is a
beautiful table full of natural herbs and flowers
putting like the grass like this when the guests come is like welcoming into the free Thailand Wow, so
Green is for time doing alright
It's really good
I'm gonna dig into the porridge first and well has a very like
Very sticky gummy kind of texture to it and all of that it almost looks like cinnamon on top sprinkle, but that's all the fenugreek
Wow the first thing I got because of that fenugreek on the top is a little bit of bitterness
Then you taste that undertone of the butter, which is yeah
It's like infused with that kind of spiciest aroma to it and almost like browned
So it has that that kind of roasted butter flavor to it
And then that's all wrapped up within the false banana porridge, which is it has a sticky texture
But at the same time it's soft. It's like gummy but also falls apart
You can tell how that would just warm you all the way to your core when it's really cold outside
We have the garlic
And yep
The the thing I forgot to share with you with the description on that first bite is that it's quite sour
because the false banana is
It's fermented for underground
for three to seven months
and kind of just skim off the top to make sure you get some fenugreek and everybody right and you can see the way that
Just kind of jiggles in your spoon that texture
The texture and the flavor is really like
Unlike anything I've ever had before
There is garlic there is the spice buttery and the first burner. My product is also the same but she instead of making porridge
She scrambled it
It's there was asked to come in Chewy
This is way softer. You can see it's more like grainy. It's like in a little little poet too much
Wow, that's a like completely different texture each little grain is like its own stickiness like little little gummy balls
But then you do taste the chili in there. The butter also makes it moist little gummy pellets
Yeah you kind of got a
Kind of gummy you got to kind of work at it and chew it
But then as you to it you get that flavor and the garlic you will have the holy water. Hmm
We use the room which you drunk mainly. Oh really, which is mainly for coffee
You know what it starts to sort of have the tapioca pearl
Texture and those little little balls to them
Just like a whole mouthful of them though. Okay. Yeah we can compete
Okay, we're gonna go see the false banana and also go around the
Compound a little bit the village but men you can just tell how that porridge it would just it's so filling
And it would just it would just sit in your stomach, but it is good
It's it's it really is a flavor combination. I've never had before
She's gonna show us the entire process of the false banana now and false
banana is one of the most important foods for the doors a
Behind me. These are all false banana's and you can see they're giant huge trunks and then the the leaves just kind of sprout
upwards
But the reason that they're called false bananas is because they don't produce fruit. They don't produce bananas that you can eat
but
What's harvested is the the stumps and that's what's used for food?
Ethiopia is one of the one of the the main places where you can eat false banana in this region. It's the staple
Weight so this is the stump part this is the stump part
So this is the stamp part which will be fermented for three months. Oh, yeah, it smells like very green banana smells like green banana
It becomes very very tough fibers
It's really really juicy as well you can see the juice coming out of it so the better there was very green
after three months of them
They smell already changed into cheesy. Mmm. Yeah, it does kind of smell cheesy like a mild cheese. Oh my god has that aroma?
It's almost like a dough that is the result of the fermentation and now
The the process before you eat it though ever before you cook it
She still has to chop it with a knife because there's so many fibers within it so that you break those fibers
And now she's she chopped it up and is mixing it with some water
So here you're gonna eat okay
This is definitely a staple food and a process and even an ingredient. I've never seen anywhere else in the world
The pancake made from the false banana had actually just prepared and it's called cocoa
and now they are they're building a fire with leaves especially so they get that flame and
Then they put the the false minutes wrapped in banana the false banana leaves. Which come from right here
And then it's gonna cook over the fire over that hot griddle
As she kept on flipping she eventually took off the banana leaves and that provides a little bit of oil for the pancake
But we're gonna head back to that hut where we ate before
And we're gonna drink some of the coffee with tea and then she's gonna bring that there as we're gonna we're gonna sample
This is again something I've never tried in something I never have never even thought of oh
Wow that's almost like a like a soup you taste
You taste the saltiness of it and you taste that garlic and then it has like almost like a tea undertone
Wow, that's that's something
That's totally new
Wow, you can really taste the garlic
This is the recorded tomato source, but it's very very spicy its Chile Chile, okay
It's very spicy
Okay
so the kocho is served and there's a little dish in the middle part of it is hundred and then part of it is a
Chili sauce so you can eat them together kind of sweet and savory at the same time
Or you can just try one of the one of the dips
Mmm all the sauce
you can taste those spices like
I can now piece dump dunked in that honey. And that's just natural honey. Ethiopia is known for honey
Well that honey is an awesome yeah thing is loving the honey
Yeah that honey is extremely good it is
slightly sour
So thick and so sweet now, I'm gonna now I'm gonna try and mix of both the chili and the honey
That's just a beautiful combination of spicy and sweet and crunchy single bye-bye. Thank you so much
We had to race down the mountain back to a dimension because we have to catch our flight
but I didn't really even get to do an ending video at the village but learning about that donut is a culture that was
Fascinating it was another learning experience the huts the culture the food totally new food that I've never seen before
And we were almost at the airport, but we're just gonna quickly stop for a very quick cup of coffee before we catch our flight
Do you remember this? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah
The frankincense is burning dip in that room Jesus Cheers
Actually, this is better. Yes
An amazing cup of coffee and we got to get to the airport now
Thank you very much
Thank you
Cool we made it to the airport. It's going to the other
It's only been it's this has been a two-part day series two days that went by really fast
If you haven't seen the first video, I'll have it linked below. Be sure to check that out now
It was an amazing day yesterday at first. I want to say a huge. Thank you to Jessie from Gladys
He's been with us this trip and he's he's such a helpful guide and such. He's so friendly he's so nice
It's been great to hang out with him. And also thank you to go honest and huggy for arranging everything
I'll leave their link in the description box below I paid for this tour
But they've done an incredible job and they just do great things. Thank you very much for watching this video
Please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it. Leave a comment below
I'd love to hear from you
And if you're not already
Subscribed be sure to click subscribe now and also click that little bell icon do get notified of the next video that I publish
Thanks again for watching
I'm just filled with energy after these two days
That was great. Ethiopia is one of my favorite countries in the world the mix of culture and food and coffee
Okay, I'm gonna end right now. Thanks for watching. See you on the next video nice shirt
Yeah summer for food to keep evidence. Yeah
desi